[Musique]
ha
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour une autre étude faite oh Allah
Mamamia entropic et discoteca Oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
be
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Je le dirai tellement
[Musique]
Chine
bien sûr
Subic tourner
pour la division comprendre
fille devrions-nous faire Gyan efficace mec
wow c'est excessif ou mesdames ouais
[Musique]
Oh
ils  ressens ça - Gobber tu verras
[Musique]
toi
Oh
[Musique]
mec
pourquoi
[Musique]
fais
[Applaudissements]
ce que tu as
vu ça
ouais
pourquoi
[Musique]
[  Musique]
pourquoi
[Musique]
ma hache
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh mon dieu je ne vois pas
[Applaudissements]
affaires
[Musique]
qui porte
ce message vous obtient
[Musique]
[  Applaudissements]
[Applaudissements]
ça va
[Mu  sic]
tu peux me rejoindre
c'est facile de survivre en
restant
Oh
[Musique]
nous jouons du bois
comme des singes
[Musique]
tu es
Oh
[Musique]
toi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements  ]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
par le sizzle booker viva la musica fall
by the  le grésillement peut être très soul oh vous
ne voulez pas dire que le bétail a dit qu'ils se baignaient -
si incroyable
[Musique]
à réviser
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Oh
CSIS notre bouche officielle Seco
[Musique]
J'ai vu un cookie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors bon sang mookee
tu gardes
ça dans  défaut sur notre nouvelle
entité extraterrestre nécessaire demandeurs d'ennemis du milieu D
opportunités de cendres de charbon de salsa pour servir
l'océan c'est une taxe que je
peux voir dans l'économie circulaire Tony
gouverneurs  ce sera entièrement dans tous les
secrets émotionnellement physiquement
malicieusement aussi pour Salinas serait
presque fini le film avec nous appréciable
Galica sous le but la position est une
solution
le caboodle de Josef et nous avons besoin d'un flash sur
WizIQ une guitare funky yella très populaire
Keisha Keisha
[Musique]
ils  sont
les faux
[Musique]
Oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
violet Emily verte a eu une journée d'école
CGT vertel un magasin un plus je dis
dis
Oh
vois que la boucle dans une bouteille dit que
s'ils mordent elle peut l'arrêter parce que tu
m'a tiré dessus mais ils disent
Oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'accord
[Musique]
sur la ligne
situation
plus je suis végétalien
[Musique]
ne dis rien
don  dis pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le dépôt ne colle pas aux coupes
peu importe petit
Dominic - maman - Tom d'accord Donny G dernier
l'opposition aliphatique va en avoir besoin,
nous nous
tournons  fais-le
[Musique
] depuis une boîte consejo de toi donc ça -
je peux le prendre
[Musique]
devrait
missile dépasser
buh da
ne dis pas
[Musique]
un simple
bonbon
[Musique]
Je m'aime
[  Musique]
un bon simple
ouais je ne m'assieds pas ne m'assieds pas en commençant
bientôt j'ai un exploit à mentionner
[Musique]
Je
pas quand un tueur en série tue un animal de compagnie facial
tommy glavine Tresca elle est bi outil a
Joseph j'approche mon pourboire d'argent  a volé un
Fisher et ça fera toujours un facial au talon
hé pour faire des blagues un gars PI o GC - est-ce que tu as la
tête sur la sienne et Saleh
si tu prends Killa - pourquoi - Wow certains disent
pourquoi
alors qu'ils ne le font pas
[Musique]
hé Julie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Elesha j'évoquerai hache égale toi comme ça à
Rachel dis par qui ont été élevés
[Musique]